6 41 on a monday morning and look who it
is it is the birthday girl monica o
jackson good morning monica happy
birthday
and thank you i appreciate it i
appreciate it i'm just happy to be alive
john
you me both all right hey did you have a
good weekend yeah it was a great weekend
it's beautiful beautiful
had a chance to get outside how about
yourself nice it was a wonderful i party
the whole month for my birthday
as you deserve to you deserve to all
right so
john you might want to listen up to this
too ladies this is for you and corporate
america it's for you as well because
things are changing you may be having
hot flashes ladies night sweats
weight gain hello been there done that
we're talking menopause
and today's money mondays with monica
now listen to this
according to this recent article in
bloomberg.com
hundreds of thousands of women are
leaving the workforce because of
menopause
now the article further stated that
productivity losses worldwide
could be in the 150
billion dollar range per year i said
billion with a b so i called local ob
gyn
dr maria keller she is here to help us
understand it and learn how to better
manage menopause in the workplace
dr keller good morning thank you so much
for being here i know you've heard these
menopause stories a million times
in your 25 year career well
as a sexual wellness physician
yeah i hear about it every day all day
so um uh it's not uncommon for women to
experience
symptoms um and they can basically
destroy
uh relationships at home as well as make
for difficulties uh at work for people
because it's
quite difficult to function if you're
extremely symptomatic
and going through uh some of the changes
of hot flashes night sweats you know
which one is going to make it hard to
sleep if you're kicking the covers on
and off
yeah that impact your emotions um it's
also uh going to um sometimes women can
get even headaches
and definitely when you're going through
all of these changes
you know who do you share this
information with it's so personal it's
so private
um especially if it uh impacts um your
ability you know
sexually in your relationship with your
partner yeah absolutely
okay you've answered my first question
already my second question is
at what point should menopausal women
seek
medical and or psychological treatment
and what would that treatment look like
so i'm going to first approach the
psychological because i think
often women get mislabeled as beings
we're given things like for the anxiety
the heart palpitations
you may be offered things like xanax or
if you're not sleeping well
ambien sleeping on medications or you
could be
um offered anti-depressants because you
go through these mood changes where
you know uh you may be extremely sad or
very angry
so you know those those have to be
addressed is that there's
often it's it doesn't require medication
it requires
picking out the right person who can
help you and and your
your for women the gynecologist should
be a place where you are to be able
to to seek help but also there's really
good resources i
i i'm a big fan and it's available to
you at your
your neighborhood sprouts um and uh uh
whole foods you can get help just over
the counter
but you know coming to the point where
you can actually have that conversation
with someone it's
such a pro and um something that is very
difficult to share and to open up about
but with
others that's what i want to jump in
here doctor because that's my next
question
at what point it you know if you have in
menopausal patients
these women are still in the workforce
at what point do you inform your
supervisor your manager like i can't
imagine going to
my mail manager and or ceo of my company
saying
you know what can i have a chat with you
because i'm going through some
menopausal issues
and i might act out here at work and i
don't want to get fired i mean
sounds kind of funny but this is real
this we're projected this is what this
article said
projected to lose 150 billion dollars a
year because these women going through
this menopause at work they cannot
tolerate
not being understood at work is what the
article
really broke it down to and then for the
bosses it's hard for them
i can't imagine them a man sitting down
listening to me tell him about my
menopause and i work for you
and or a woman and you're who's your
boss and she's 30 years old right
when you're 45 i mean that's difficult
for them to be able
to relate i as a physician could not
relate to women until i became
40. yeah and i started experiencing what
we call perimenopause
the symptoms can begin in the mid-30s
you don't have to be
uh you know 50 or 60 years of age to
start experiencing these symptoms
i think the thing is is for us to
educate and to get the word out so that
people
can be aware that these symptoms are
real and they do
impact people's lives and their ability
to perform because
how can you perform at your best when
you haven't slept for days
when you went because the hot flashes
and the night sweats
you know kick on at night and you tried
benadryl but you know benadryl might
make you sleep until you have a hot
flash for a night
you know now you have to change and you
have to relax yourself to get back to
sleep so
um a big part of it is for um corporate
america has to
be aware that there are a lot 20 percent
of the workforce
of their employees are experiencing
these symptoms at some point
or another absolutely okay at what point
though doc and i got to wrap it up here
this
real quick at what point should you go
in how should the conversation go with
you and your boss
you walk in the office you sit down
you're having issues real quick tell us
i think it's important for you to let
them know some of the symptoms that
you're experiencing that
you recognize that it is related to your
hormones and that your hormones um
are actually um uh you you feel that
this may be a part of it
and that you are planning to seek and to
get help or to do
something about it okay there's some
books out there that you can read
one is called um one is called i'm sorry
about that one is called
uh uh uh menopause what your doctor may
not tell you and it's written by
dr john lee a very good book for what
was the bible for me
when i learned because i had to
recognize these symptoms as well and to
find
a simple solution to um to get them
you know to help my patients and natural
progesterone is that simple solution
something that you can get at walm uh
not walmart but at uh
uh whole foods or sprouts you know a
place that sells natural
kind of uh remedies i have to i have to
jump in because i'm out of time i want
to make sure folks are able to get a
hold of you
so if they want to talk to you further
about this uh tell us the number it's
right there on your screen but go ahead
and call it out for us
702-546-5483 or 546
live live eve which is livageously you
know i'm promoting
getting older without feeling older and
certainly go to the website to read the
information
it's written whether you come see me or
not i wrote that website
for women to have information about what
hormones can do and what they don't do
it does not affect hormones but
if you're very symptomatic and your
colleagues are bringing it out
and making it a point to your attention
or your loved ones at home
do something about it okay dr keller
thank you so much obviously this is a
conversation that's going to keep
happening
and i think we're going to see more
fallout from corporate america as well
thank you we appreciate you
all right folks and hey don't forget to
catch the moj show facebook
live weeknights at seven i appreciate uh
dr keller here
yeah sherry so i'm as i'm reading this
article when they said 150 million
dollars is going to start hitting
corporate america we're going to lose it
because these women 45 to 55
they're in the age group where they're
supposed to be in upper management but
they're leaving the workforce oh that's
it's going to hit
employers hard for sure